البدايه اذا باخر تطورات الحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه حيث قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان ضابطا وجنديا قتل واصيب
ثلاثه بجروح خطيره خلال المعارك الدائره
شمال وجنوب قطاع غزه من رام الله مراسله
الجزيره جيفاره البديري مقتل ضابط وجندي
واصابه ثلاثه عسكريين اخرين هل هناك
تفاصيل اكثر في هذا
الشان بالطبع سهام الجيش الاسرائيلي هو
فقط يعلن في صباح كل يوم وفي ساعات المساء
عن الحصيله الجديده المحدثه هو تحدث صباح
هذا ال اليوم عن مقتل ضابط وجندي واصابه
ثلاثه اخرين بجراح وصفت بال خطيره في
اليوم الس
77 للحرب على غزه بذلك يرتفع عدد الجنود
والضباط القتلى منذ السابع من اكتوبر الى
171 جنديا وضابطا ومنذ بدء العمليه البريه
والهجوم البري على قطاع غزه يرتفع العدد
الى
145 جنديا وضابطا ايضا في ساعات متاخره من
مساء امس وحتى ساعات الفجر كان هناك
اجتماع لمجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي لم يتم
الافصاح عما دار فيه لكن بعض وسائل
الاعلام الاسرائيليه تاك تحدثت عن وجود
خلافات كبيره لازالت موجوده بين الاعضاء
الخمسه ما بين ال مضي قدما في محاوله
تسهيل الوصول الى عمليه وصفقه تبادل جديده
وما بين الرفض ووجوب الاستمرار بالهجوم
العسكري ايضا كان الناطق ال العسكري باسم
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد صرح بانه ت تم
استهداف اكثر من 2000 من مقاتلي كتائب
القسام ومن فصائل اخرى ولم يحدد وذلك
بقصفهم من البر والبحر والجو في مواقع عده
في قطاع غزه ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول
ان ما تعرف بالكتيبه 36 اكملت السيطره
عمليا على حي الشجاعيه غير مفهوم ما معنى
عمليا بمعنى ان لازالت هناك معارك ضاريه
واشتباكات مسلحه ومن مسافه صفر والجنود
يتحدثون عن انهم يواجهون مقاتلين شرسين اي
بمعنى عناصر المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكان
ايضا مساء امس قد حدث الكثير من البلبله
حول ما معنى سحب لواء جولاني فرقه وهي ال
الكتيبه 13 في وا جولاني من داخل قطاع غزه
هذا معناه وفق بعض المراقبين العسكريين
الاسرائيليين ان الحديث عن اعاده تنظيم
وهيكله في داخل قطاع غزه وليس عن انسحاب
فقط اعاده موضع موضع وهيكل للقوات على
الارض ولكن يجب ان نتحدث هنا ايضا عن
المستوى السياسي فيما يدور من لغط حول
قضيه ايه صفقه التبادل واضح ان هناك تباين
كبير هيئه البث الرسميه الاسرائيليه تقول
ان اسرائيل تحاول من خلال الوسطاء العمل
على زياده ايام الهدنه مقابل رفع عدد
الاسرى الاسرائيليين الذين يمكن الافراج
عنهم خاصه ان اسرائيل لازالت تصر على ان
هناك
17 امراه وطفل لازالوا اسرى في داخل قطاع
غزه بينما تؤكد الم المصادر الاسرائيليه
ان المشكله هي ان حركه حماس ترفض ذلك
والحركه تصر كما كنا قد استمعنا من خلال
ايضا المسؤولين من الحركه بانه لن يكون
هناك مفاوضات الا بعد وقف شامل وكامل
لاطلاق النار اذا اسرائيل تناور في موضوع
زياده عدد ايام الهدنه بينما حركه حماس
تصر على انه يجب ان يكون هناك وقف كام
لاطلاق النار نتنياهو و جانس يصران على من
خلال ما يتم التصريح به على ان الحرب
متواصله بانه لن يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق
النار ان اهداف اسرائيل ستبقى كما هي
واساسها القضاء على حركه حماس والافراج عن
كل الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في داخل
قطاع غزه ولكن واضح من خلال كل ما يحدث
خلف الكواليس ان اسرائيل تحاول وبكل الطرق
من خلال الوسطاء العمل للوصول الى صفقه
جديده ولكن واضح ان الصفقه تجد الكثير من
العراقيل ايضا على الصعيد
العسكري قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقول
انها تمكنت من كشف المزيد من فتحات
الانفاق وشبكه انفاق فيما سمته مربع
المسؤولين في مدينه غزه شبكه انفاق تربط
شقق سكنيه مكاتب
وا مواقع تمكن من خلالها القاده العسكريين
من التنقل خلال هذه الحرب وعلى مدار
تحديدا الاسابيع
ماضيه ولكن حتى الان واضح انه من خلال
استمرار اطلاق الصواريخ تحديدا اتجاه
تلبيب ووصولا الى هرتسيليا شمالا وايضا
كما حدث بالامس في تلبيب الكبرى في تح
تجفا في اسدود في هرتسيليا في غيرها ان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره وقويه كما كانت
في السابق بمواصله اطلاق الصواريخ من
المناطق التي اصلا يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه اكمل السيطره عليها ولكن واضح ان
استمرار اطلاق الصواريخ يجعل من مجلس
الحرب في مهمه اصعب واصعب و حسب وصف
المراقبين السياسيين الاسرائيليين بانه ما
يتم الحديث عنه في العلن هو ليس ما يحدث
على الارض وان بالفعل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
لازالت قادره على توجيه الصواريخ وايضا
مواصله القتال من مسافه صفر في داخل
الميدان خاصه في خانيونس حي الشجاعيه
وايضا من مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع الذي كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي قد قالت انها اكملت السيطره
عليها ولكن واضح على الارض ان ذلك لم يتم
بالفعل شكرا لك جفار البديري مراسله
الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله